faire entendre le camp des travailleurs
c'est le slogan du parti lutte ouvrière
mais aussi le but de leur combat attrape
une liste l eau est conduite par patrick
planque un ouvrier de maintenance
ferroviaire on a rencontré des
travailleurs un peu partout sur les
marchés dans les entreprises dans les
quartiers où on est allé prospecter on
est allé faire du porte à porte il ya
une vraie inquiétude de la part des
salariés et à une vraie inquiétude de la
part des travailleurs sur la situation
et le fait qu'ils aient une liste dans
ces élections qui défendent un point de
vue ouvriers un point de vue de
travailleurs lutte de classes qui ont
envie de se bagarrer et bien ça va
changer un peu les choses une réunion
publique avait lieu vendredi 1er octobre
à la maison des familles objectif
présenter la liste et les grandes idées
c'est ça notre programme c'est un
programme de lutte c'est pas un
programme avec des promesses électorales
en disant voté pour nous et on va
changer les choses non c'est un
programme pour dire oui il faut que les
travailleurs s'organisent ils se
défendent ils se préparent à une bagarre
offensive contre les contre le patronat
contre le gouvernement quelques
sympathisants militants ou candidat sur
la liste ont débattu et des problèmes
liés à trappes et plus généralement en
france changer les relais
toute la structure de
désavantages qu'il ya certaines
personnes que je trouve très très
difficile à tenir avec les budgets coin
qu'ils ont dans cette mairie je
travaille chez
je suis une salariée comme tous les
salariés on a besoin de défendre les
salariés je te dis même pas on est quand
même que je vais dire si on ne défend
pas qui va les défendre c'est pas le
gouvernement qui va les défendre
oui les élections municipales partielles
de trappes se dérouleront les 10 et 17
octobre prochains